Wie kommt ihr morgens aus'm Bett?
*Wecker klingelt*
Sind Frühaufsteher einfach fleißiger?
Oder ist es biologisch?
Ihr habt abgestimmt.
Viele bezeichnen sich als Eulen.
Also als Spätaufsteher
und -zubettgeher.
Wisst ihr, was dahinter steckt?
Ist das alles nur Gewohnheit,
oder liegt's in euren Genen?
Zwingt uns die Gesellschaft dazu,
gegen unsere Natur zu früh
aufzustehen? Das klären wir jetzt.
*Titelmusik*
Wir haben eine innere Uhr.
Nachts sind wir müde,
tagsüber sind wir wach.
Aber nicht nur unser Schlaf richtet
sich danach, auch andere Funktionen.
Z. B. ist unsere Körpertemperatur
zwischen 4 und 6 Uhr morgens
am tiefsten
und nachmittags am höchsten.
Selbst wenn ich eingesperrt bin,
ohne Uhr, regelmäßiges Licht,
regelmäßige Mahlzeiten,
z. B. im Schlaflabor,
läuft mein innerer Rhythmus
immer noch weiter.
Jetzt sieht man aber im Schlaflabor,
dass die innere Uhr von Menschen
meistens nicht exakt 24 h lang ist.
24 h, 10 min ist der Mittelwert
über viele Menschen.
Hier seht ihr die inneren Tageslängen
von 129 Menschen, die an der Studie
teilgenommen haben.
Bei den meisten ist sie
ein paar Minuten länger als 24 h.
bei anderen kürzer, bei manchen
auch viel länger oder viel kürzer.
So, wie lange jetzt
mein innerer Tag ist
das liegt in unseren Genen.
Und hier kommen wir zu...
Erst mal ganz allgemein,
in unseren Genen steckt Information.
Und diese Information kann gelesen
und übersetzt werden.
In der Praxis heißt das,
dass nach Anleitung des Gens
ein Protein hergestellt werden kann.
Dieses Protein hat dann
irgendeine biologische Funktion.
Wir haben auch Gene, die für
unsere innere Uhr zuständig sind.
Nennen wir sie "Uhren-Gene".
Und diese Uhren-Gene
können abgelesen werden
und produzieren Uhren-Proteine.
Diese Uhren-Proteine
sammeln sich zunächst einmal an.
Doch dann kommt es
zu einer Rückkopplung.
Die Uhren-Proteine verhindern es,
dass die eigenen Gene
weiter abgelesen werden.
Es werden keine Proteine
mehr hergestellt,
und der Uhren-Protein-Haufen
wird nach und nach abgebaut.
Wenn das Uhren-Protein weg ist,
kann das Gen wieder abgelesen werden.
Es kann neues Protein produzieren,
und der ganze Zyklus
fängt wieder von vorne an.
Und das Ganze dauert eben
ungefähr 24 h.
Das ist unsere innere Uhr.
Jetzt gibt es
bei verschiedenen Menschen
verschiedene
genetische Besonderheiten.
Die führen beim einen dazu,
dass der Zyklus länger dauert,
beim anderen, dass er kürzer dauert.
Und hier kommen wir jetzt zu...
Fangen wir an mit den Lerchen.
Die Lerchen sind die Vögel,
die angeblich den Wurm fangen.
Sie stehen früh auf
und gehen früh schlafen.
In ihrer molekularen inneren Uhr
werden die Uhr-Proteine
besonders schnell abgebaut,
so dass ihr Zyklus kürzer ist.
Wenn der eigene innere Tag kürzer ist
als 24 h,
muss man seine innere Uhr
jeden Tag bisschen nachstellen.
So wird man früher wach.
Bei den Eulen
ist es genau anders rum.
Eulen stehen lieber später auf,
sind aber länger wach.
Hier ist die innere Uhr länger
als 24 h.
Deshalb pendeln sie sich
auch später im Tag erst ein.
Sie müssen jeden Tag
die Uhr vorstellen, so wie ich.
Viele von euch
halten mich für eine Lerche,
aber nein, ich bin...
Ich bin so was von 'ne Eule!
Weiß auch nicht,
warum meine Videos 6.30 Uhr kommen.
Aber die Frage
nach Eulen oder Lerchen
ist selten ein entweder oder.
Wir haben es hier mit einem
kontinuierlichen Spektrum zu tun,
und die meisten sind in der Mitte.
Doch ist die Lösung für mich
und alle anderen Eulen
nicht einfach nur...
*Lärm*
Ein ziemlich lauter Wecker?
Sorry!
Klar, der Wecker
bringt auch jede Eule aus dem Bett.
Nur ihre innere Uhr
steht trotzdem noch auf nachts.
Und das macht sich bemerkbar.
Z. B. ist die Konzentrationsfähigkeit
nachweislich schlechter.
- Mai-Thi?
- Ja?
Selbst, wenn die Eule
eigentlich genug geschlafen hat.
Sidenote: Spätaufsteher
sind nicht automatisch Langschläfer.
Genauso wie verschiedene Menschen
verschieden lange innere Uhren haben,
haben verschiedene Menschen auch
verschieden lange
optimale Schlafzeiten.
Im Durchschnitt braucht
ein erwachsener Mensch 8 h Schlaf.
Aber bei manchen ist es mehr,
bei anderen weniger.
Und das ist unabhängig davon,
ob man Eule oder Lerche ist.
Allerdings kriegen Eulen
tatsächlich zu wenig Schlaf,
wenn man sie
zum frühen Aufstehen zwingt.
Denn trotzdem werden sie
erst später am Tag müde,
wenn sie dann früh aufstehen,
haben sie zu wenig geschlafen.
Je länger man das durchzieht,
umso schlimmer wird’s.
Und was die Folgen von Schlafentzug
sind, dazu hatten wir ja schon
ein ganzes Video
zusammen mit Techtastisch.
Tja, und jetzt?
Es wird Zeit für ein Tutorial.
Die innere Uhr richtig stellen.
Alles, was wir regelmäßig tun,
Mahlzeiten, Sport,
das alles kann als Zeitgeber dienen,
um die Uhr richtig zu stellen.
Am effektivsten ist aber Licht.
Menschen, die vollkommen blind sind,
haben Probleme, ihre innere Uhr
an die Tageszeit anzupassen.
Trotz regelmäßiger Schlafzeiten,
Mahlzeiten und Aktivitäten.
Sind sie Lerchen,
werden sie immer früher müde.
Sind sie Eulen, später.
Deswegen ist Licht
die wichtigste Stellschraube
für unsere innere Uhr.
Das beste Licht gibt es immer noch
von der Sonne, Freunde der Sonne.
Selbst an einem bewölkten Tag
ist Tageslicht 2 - 3x so hell
wie ein beleuchtetes Arbeitszimmer.
Und in der prallen Sonne
ist es etwa 130x heller.
Deshalb ist rausgehen das beste
Mittel, um die innere Uhr zu stellen.
Wie gut das funktioniert,
zeigt diese Studie.
Bei der Forscher mit den
Versuchsteilnehmern zelten gingen.
Und zwar in Colorado,
in den Rocky Mountains. Gönnt euch!
Nach einer Woche Zelten
stand die innere Uhr
geschlagene zwei Stunden früher
als vorher.
Beim Zelten waren jetzt
die Eulen immer noch Eulen
und die Lerchen
immer noch Lerchen.
Aber der Unterschied
zwischen beiden wurde kleiner.
V. a. die Eulen wurden viel früher
wach als im normalen Stadtleben.
Jetzt scheint es
unter den Freunden der Sonne
besonders viele Eulen zu geben.
Nur das hier ist nicht repräsentativ
für die ganze Bevölkerung.
Eine Frage des Alters.
Es ist ganz interessant,
wie spät unsere innere Uhr
eingependelt ist,
das ändert sich mit dem Alter.
Als Kind sind wir relativ früh dran.
So zwischen 16 und 25 verschiebt sich
das Ganze nach hinten.
Und als Erwachsene
sind wir wieder früher dran.
Und zwar gilt das sowohl für Eulen
als auch für Lerchen.
Das hat nicht unbedingt was damit zu
tun, dass Junge nachts gerne feiern
oder bis drei Uhr nachts
mailab-Videos schauen.
Man sieht diesen Unterschied auf
der ganzen Welt in allen Kulturen.
Einschl. der Hadza, die in Tansania
noch als Jäger und Sammler leben.
D. h. diese jugendliche "Euligkeit"
die scheint biologisch zu sein.
Was heißt das jetzt?
Aus all den Gründen,
die ich gerade genannt habe,
fordern Schlafforscher immer wieder,
dass weiterführende Schulen erst um 9
statt um 8 Uhr anfangen sollen.
Also,
liebe Lehrerinnen und Lehrer,
vielleicht ist's für euch kein
Problem, um 8 Uhr munter zu sein.
Aber für eure Schüler
ist es noch mitten in der Nacht.
Schickt euren Lehrern dieses Video!
Aber vergesst auch nicht,
in einem gewissen Rahmen
könnt ihr eure Uhr verstellen,
und zwar am besten mit Licht.
Ab in die Sonne, Freunde der Sonne!
Wir sehen uns in der Endcard.
Nächste Woche
geht es bei mailab um Burnout.
Wenn ihr Fragen habt
oder Kommentare, Input,
schreibt alles gern in die Kommentare
unter #Burnout.
So kann ich das leichter finden
und mit einfließen lassen.
Wir befinden uns immer noch
in der Montagstestphase.
D. h. nächste Woche sehen wir
uns wieder mal am Montag.
Bis dahin!
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2018)